[Musique]
élu par les internautes à trois reprises
et cette année encore plus belles gares
de france inscrits à l'inventaire des
monuments historiques depuis 1975 la
gare de metz est un bâtiment hors du
commun symbole des rivalités franco
allemande pendant un demi siècle elle
porte les traces de cette histoire
tragique et pas seulement parce qu'elle
est le lieu officiel de la mort de jean
moulin en 1943 lors de son transfert
pour l'allemagne à l'occasion des
journées du patrimoine 2021 ce week end
du 18 et 19 septembre la sncf vous ouvre
les portes du salon d'honneur de la gare
et des recoins habituellement
inaccessibles c'est l'occasion de
découvrir son histoire
le gouvernement parisien tergiverse
depuis les années 1830 pour la création
d'une ligne de chemin de fer à
destination de l'est dans cette optique
chaque ville milite pour faire passer le
train tard chez elle les crédits de la
ligne paris strasbourg sont votées en
1842 sous la monarchie de juillet mais
il n'y a au départ pas de liaisons
prévues à destination de metz une voie
pour relier messe à nancy est construite
en 1850 et la ville se dote d'une gare
provisoire un embarcadère en bois
aménagé à l'extérieur des remparts une
nouvelle porte il est d'ailleurs percée
pour accéder à la gare et elle est
nommée porte serpenoise elle est
toujours visible aujourd'hui c'est
désormais un arc de triomphe forme que
lui ont donné les amis le premier trajet
au départ de metz a lieu le 10 juillet
1850 et la gare permanente n'est mise en
service qu'en avril 1853 il s'agit d'une
gare terminus qui n'a que deux voies à
destination du sud pour rejoindre le
nord thionville luxembourg par exemple
on repart aussi vers le sud pour trouver
un embranchement cette première gare de
metz n'est plus visible dans le paysage
puisqu'elle a disparu dans un incendie
en 1872
lorsqu'éclate la guerre avec la prusse
en 1870 l'est de la france voit se
diriger de nombreux trains vers l'est
mais dans un désordre total les soldats
manque les wagons ne sont pas des
charges et le terminus de metz voit se
constituer un immense embouteillage
ferroviaire
la ville de metz a siégé à partir du 19
août 1870 avec 150 mille soldats à
l'intérieur des murs fini par se rendre
tout comme la ville de paris quelques
mois plus tard la guerre est perdue et
l'alsace moselle est annexé à ce qui est
devenu entre-temps lempire allemand la
ville de metz et donc intégré au
territoire allemand dans le land
d'alsace lorraine et la frontière passe
désormais à dix kilomètres de la ville
le reich envisage immédiatement la
construction d'une grande gare centrale
à metz en lieu et place de la gare
française située à l'extérieur de la
ville puisque metz est désormais une
ville frontière il faut lui donner les
moyens de défendre l' empire
dès la fin de l'année 1872 la liaison
ferroviaire entre metz et berlin est
acté les allemands renonce finalement à
trouver de la place dans l'enceinte des
retards pour la nouvelle gare les voies
existent déjà et le site est libre pour
un agrandissement conséquent cette
deuxième gare la première gare allemande
est inaugurée en 1878 et elle est
aujourd'hui appelée ancienne gare elle a
abrité pendant longtemps des bureaux de
la sncf et doit prochainement accueillir
un centre statistiques de l'insee
toutefois cette gare ne permet pas de
réaliser les grands projets défensive de
l'empereur guillaume ii la france est
désormais alliée à la russie et
l'allemagne est menacée sur deux fronts
le 16e corps d'armée du reich est
stationné dans la ville mais il doit
pouvoir être rejoint rapidement par des
renforts et recevoir du matériel en
quantité la disposition en cul-de-sac de
la gare de metz exige de l'ong manoeuvre
de train pour y remédier les allemands à
battre les remparts de la ville en 1898
et un premier projet de garde passage
est élaboré l'année d'après pour
remplacer l'existante
l' ordonnance impériale qui décide la
construction de la nouvelle gare de metz
est signée en avril 1901 par l'empereur
allemand ce grand projet répond à des
intérêts pratiques stratégique mais
aussi symbolique après 30 ans d'annexion
la majorité des lorrains restent en
effet toujours hostiles à la présence
allemande
la construction d'une nouvelle gare est
donc l'occasion d'ancrer dans le paysage
la domination germanique
le nouveau site choisi pour cette gare
qui n'est plus un terminus mais une
carte passage et 300 mètres plus à l'est
les travaux de terrassement met au jour
les fondations d'amphithéâtre de la
colonie romaine de niveaux de zoom en
périphérie du champ tiff cet
amphithéâtre l'un des plus grands de
gaulle avec ses 148 par 124 mètres de
diamètre n'a malheureusement pas
conserver d'élévation puisqu'il a servi
au fil des siècles de carrière de
pierres
quoi qu'il en soit l'empereur guillaume
ii prend la décision dans fois les
vestiges pour continuer les travaux ils
visitent d'ailleurs lui-même le chantier
en mai 1903
le concours pour la réalisation de la
nouvelle gare est ouvert en décembre
1901 à tous les architectes allemands le
cahier des charges est très strict et
prévoit déjà beaucoup d'événements
circulation salon impérial façade
lumineuse etc
le lauréat est l'architecte jürgen
krueger qui doit quand même modifier son
plan pour adopter un style plus
officielles sont toutefois brusquer les
messins hostile à la germanisation yom
deux souhaitent un style rappelant
l'appartenance de metz à à l'empiré
carolingien médiéval un style roman
durant kruger ou touche donc à la marge
les lignes qu'il a dessinée ajout des
voûtes en plein cintre des irrégularités
pittoresque et des motifs médiévaux tiré
de manuels d'histoire de l'art bestiaire
entre la stylisé rosas il s'inspire pour
cela du renouveau au roman étasunien lui
même emprunté à la france ironie de
l'histoire la propagande impériale
allemande n'arrive pas à se passer de
l'insolence française la gare qui devait
coûter 2 millions de marks en coûte
finalement 29 conséquence de
l'instabilité du terrain le choix du
site est mauvais pour accueillir un tel
bâtiment la couche d'argile solide est à
15 mètres de profondeur les ingénieurs
allemands enfonce dans le sol plus de
3000 pieux en béton armé en guise de
fondation les travaux commencent
finalement en novembre 1905 et se
poursuivre pendant presque trois ans
vitrine de lempire la gare est alimentée
dès sa création à l'électricité pour son
éclairage et et faire fonctionner la
grande horloge celle ci est installée en
mai 1908 au sommet de sa tour de 40
mètres et elle témoigne tout de même de
l'esprit art nouveau que voulait à
l'origine l'architecte kruger puisque
les heures ne sont pas marquées par des
numéros mais par des poupe
l'édifice est inaugurée le 17 août 1908
en même temps que les voix qui contourne
la ville à l'est et au nord la garde
mais ce n'est désormais plus un
cul-de-sac l'empereur guillaume ii la
visite neuf jours après l'inauguration
c'est l'occasion pour lui de visiter le
salon construits spécialement son
honneur car l' architecture intérieure
est assez remarquable une partie de la
gare réservé à l'empereur et à ses hôtes
de marque on accède à ce salon d'honneur
par l'extérieur de lyon en basalte gare
de l'entrée à l'intérieur à un escalier
en arbre conduit à la salle de réception
l'entrée est aussi gardé par deux
lionnes et il ya comme un air de mycènes
fouillé d'ailleurs au 19e siècle par un
allemand heinrich schliemann
le salon est ornée de scènes de chasse
dont l'empereur guillaume ii raffolait
un grand doute rail représente
l'empereur charlemagne en majesté conçu
pour rappeler à metz calé depuis des
siècles intégré à un empire germanique
certains disent
les yeux sera mieux
avec l'angleterre
le coût de tout élitisme deux ans
l'uac le bas du losange et on ose
carroger carolus charlemagne étant aussi
revendiquée par les français ce vitrail
a été conservée jusqu'à nos jours
contrairement à celui en face qui
représentait l'aigle impérial allemand
ce salon est ouvert lors des journées du
patrimoine ce week end 18 et 19
septembre alors profitez-en
l'entrée des voyageurs se fait par la
façade principale est aussi richement
décorées sur la grande voûte sont
représentés dans les entrelacs
d'inspiration romane des figures du
peuple en voyage divers métiers sont
montrés musiciens militaires francisé
après 1918 bûcheron porter femme à
l'enfant etc
au sommet trône désormais le blason de
la lorraine remplaçants l'aigle impérial
originel dont on devine encore la forme
des ailes sur la pierre
sous la voûte il y a quatre portraits
sculptés celui qui porte la plume
représente kruger l'architecte de la
gare deux allégories féminine aux
extrémités de la façade représentent les
deux provinces annexée l'alsace à gauche
et la lorraine à droite toujours sur la
façade des chevaux soufflant par les
naseaux symbolise la puissance du cheval
vapeur et une autre relief représente
les différents moyens de transport dans
l' empire de nombreux autres détails
sont à dénicher dans tous les recoins à
l'intérieur est clair pour signaler
l'emplacement du transformateur
électrique ciseaux et rasoirs pour
l'emplacement du coiffeur
les salles d'attentes sont aussi truffé
de barrow liasses montrant les scènes de
la vie de la gare et reflètent les
écarts de richesse entre les voyageurs
qui fréquentent la première et la
troisième classe
vers la gauche les bâtiments de service
sont ornés de sculptures des personnels
de la gare médecin reconnaissable à son
quai du ctd graphiste enroulé dans sa
bande comme dans une écharpe ou encore
agent de circulation fumant sa pipe
plusieurs salles d'attentes sont prévues
pour les voyageurs vaste et aérée et
éclairé par des vitraux les voyageurs de
1ère et 2ème classe peuvent accéder au
buffet restaurants qui ont dans leur
cave les meilleurs français et les
meilleurs bien à demande la gare qu'on
dit qu'est au total chacun consacré à
une destination mais les indications en
langue française sont toutefois
soigneusement évité ce qui agace passe
humblement les mais sans cette gare en
effet concentré beaucoup de ressentiment
considéré comme prussienne son
architecture est critiqué par beaucoup
d'habitants de la ville cela est bien
sûr dû à la profusion d'allégories et
décors destinée à rappeler la domination
germanique la symbolique de la gare à
d'ailleurs fait l'objet de plusieurs
travaux universitaires dont ceux de
thomas ce bonus et je ne m'excuse pour
la prononciation je ne parle pas
allemand
même si après 1918 les aigles matériaux
ont été remplacés par le blason de la
ville comme sur le portail du salon
d'honneur style durant les allégories de
la guerre et de l'industrie bon nombre
de symboles allemands restent visibles
ce sont notamment les corniches
représentants des batailles des germains
contre les uns ou contre les romains ses
exploits en tic notamment menée par le
chef armin us sont la plus pure
expression du nationalisme allemand mais
l'élément le plus emblématique de cette
querelle nationale dont la gare de metz
a été l'instrument est situé au pied de
la tour de l'horloge c'est là que le
maréchal von hessler longtemps chef du
corps d'armée de metz reçoit sa statue
sa tête est échangé en 1919 par les
français et une croix de lorraine
remplace l'aigle sur son bouclier mais
la victoire allemande de 1940 et la
réélection de l'alsace moselle au reich
allemand qu'on lui une nouvelle fois à
modifier la statue les allemands
trouvent que le chevalier français
ressemble un peu trop maréchal foch et
le recouvre d'une bâche en attendant de
modifier ses traits c'est chose faite en
1942 la stature retrouve le visage du
maréchal allemand et la croix de
lorraine est remplacé par le blason de
la ville de metz queuleu bouclier arbore
encore aujourd'hui enfin en 1944 à la
libération de la ville la tête tombe à
nouveau et on n'en scrute une quatrième
et dernière toujours en place
aujourd'hui
[Musique]
cette guerre n'est plus de nos jours
détesté par les messins bien au
contraire l'aga arrive même
régulièrement en tête des monuments
régionaux favori de la population son
classement à l'inventaire des monuments
historiques et la réconciliation franco
allemande ont fait oublier lé symbole de
l'impérialisme pour laisser apparaître
toute la richesse de son iconographie
une superbe découverte profité de ce
week-end pour visiter ce lieu ça vaut
vraiment le coup vous trouverez toutes
les informations dans la barre des lieux
sous la vidéo je remercie la sncf et
toutes les personnes qui ont contribué à
sa réalisation et je vous donne rendez
vous mercredi pour un nouvel épisode
d'ici là n'oubliez pas de vous abonner
partager un clic et et si vous le
souhaitez vous pouvez soutenir la chaîne
via your type notament le lien est juste
ici un grand merci à mercredi prochain
[Musique]